[Music]  nice pad  richard you haven't changed it on bruce  you might be surprised  what was that back there a mess it's a  way to keep my lives  separate i can't think of the last time  we saw each other  i bet you can remember the last time the  first time too  i'm eager to learn they all say that ben  turner richard dragon  shiva disciplined honorable  [Music]  she's very dedicated  ben shiva i assume you're in some kind  of trouble  the cobra cult a worldwide organization  of murderous zealots  kill them we have to stop it no matter  what  i ain't ever gonna turn down whooping  somebody's ass  no matter how much you train evil  remains  we're not done yet again  a quarry is a bit more formidable than  we thought  that's handy  this isn't going to be easy  remember you are stronger together than  [Music]  apart  [Music]  you